foreign
where'd you grow up where are you from
originally I grew up in uh Arizona
Phoenix Metropolis area I was born in
Glendale and grew up mostly in the north
Phoenix area with my grandmother
tell me about your family growing up
um I didn't have a mom I didn't have my
dad
when my dad was around he was very very
violent abusive
my grandmother wasn't the best she
didn't like my mom's side of the family
and she did many things to keep me from
being like my mom's side of the family
in the end my grandmother kind of but
nevertheless pressed me to be more like
them
um I was grew up like any normal boy at
least a normal boy on medications for
whatever reasons
um my first therapist around 11 would
come to find out that
by the things I were just doing the way
I was acting that there was a good
chance I had a gender identity issue
that's what he said
and though I uh when I was three my
grandmother got I used to dress and goes
close to the day my grandma got me a
dress I have for Christmas uh she beat
the [ __ ] on me when I said I could be I
could really be a girl she had me put on
medications uh trying to deter me from
being what she thought was an issue or
something that's not right or normal
first time I ever came out to myself
about being transgender or whatnot I was
16.
and I cried I was crying in the bathroom
because I couldn't figure out why God
had made me born wrong did you did you
feel like your family just didn't accept
it my grandmother didn't accept him she
still doesn't to this day she says are
you done with that phase of return she
gets
my mother over openly accepted it
because of my grandmother who is was
once my grandfather has been a woman for
26 years now so it was very easy for my
mom to accept the fact she even gave me
the original name she would have given
me if I was naturally born and girl
because I you don't get to pick your
name when you're born so I figured my
mom had the right to pick my name and
she didn't give me the name Karen it was
once Andrew but my name is now Taryn
and that's not by my choice I wanted
Charlene honestly so your birth name
your given name was Andrew and my birth
name given again would be uh Taran
considering she had them both picked out
for me it just didn't know what gender I
was still there I was born oh I see okay
it was a matter of what I came out as is
what a name I would have been given
originally so Taryn is a combination of
Teresa and Karen my mother and her her
sister's name my aunt
they didn't have the best uh mom growing
up per se
as a
joke you said I have an uncle grandpa
because of that my my actual grandmother
on my mom's side married her son
so she was never kind to her own
daughters
um
though
my mom was never there I I somehow grew
a very big bond to my mom
just because she was the only person in
my family to not lie to me about
anything in my past or things like that
or not make up things and even when
asked why she wasn't there
and I knew the answer the answer is
you're too immaturity grow up and stop
doing drugs irregardless if you thought
it was from my best interest the fact
Still Remains you did not want to grow
up and be a parent my mom didn't deny
that my mom actually said I did what was
in your best interest so I thought but
because
I was too immature to grow up and stop
getting high at the time my child and I
still haven't grown up to the quickening
high and I still get high and it was the
that sheer honesty to the even that that
that most
um
heartbreaking of realities
that made me love my mom in the end
um
I would meet my wife when I was turned
21. you were married
my wife yeah the one I married yeah I
met her when I was 21. it's funny to be
sick she was a birthday gift
funny thing to be said but it's an
honest truth she really was a gift from
my friends
I just met her that day and next thing
you know I would forever be with her we
would get married after four years and
together and
we stayed married for
another six years
and six months and three days
a year ago I actually ended up producing
my wife
um she had Hashimoto's and after so many
pregnancy she wasn't supposed to have
any more kids when I got with her she
already had five
our first one together was our sixth one
and our second one was our seventh we
were told she wasn't allowed to have any
more kids because it would kill her
well I was against her killing herself
or dying that way and I told her that I
wanted to have an abortion
unfortunately after going so many years
of not having kids again and whatnot
when she found out she was pregnant she
was reluctant to tell me
and she didn't tell me until after they
were born the CPS had come in taking
them because we already had our rights
terminated to our first one
so his take one take all they take every
kid from us since then
your wife was older than you were no
yeah my wife was uh seven and a half
years older than I was but if you saw a
picture of her you would you would
wouldn't believe she was over 18. and
that's a real true fact
my wife had an unbelievable beauty that
surpassed anything I could imagine for
being her age
she made me look like I was in my 50s
sometimes
she really really was beautiful girl
um
and it just seemed the more the years
went by the the more she she didn't age
it was amazing the day I met her she
looked the same as the day she passed
away
she passed away from
um heart her heart gave out
leaving her um without a heartbeat for
46 minutes before they got her heart
restarted and at this time
her heart had stopped with with the two
pregnancies before the last one
uh she was left 19 brain dead after the
first pregnancy 48 after the second one
it was a miracle that she functioned as
well as she did but after the third one
she was left 98 brain dead and
Hollywood pre-listerian Hospital on
September 16th three days after my
birthday I held her seeing the Bronze
Lullaby as she passed away
in my arms
it was the hardest moment I've ever had
to face in my life
not even losing my kids or anything it
had been so hard because For the first
time in my life
I was absolutely alone
I had no friends no family no one but my
cats
and the housing on my me my wife's
apartment lasted for a year
and we recently lost
the housing though it was just me and
the housing was in her name I don't know
why it went on so long
but I was left with just our three cats
and
just two days ago one of them got eaten
and
I've never really been so alone in my
life I I don't have the will to really
want to do much anymore except for just
go wherever
I say it's God's voice and my wife
talking to me honestly but whatever it
says to do like even coming down here
and doing this today wasn't because of
the money it was because
so I felt like my wife was saying maybe
I should do it
so I put myself
in the car and
did it
um
my my days of where I'm going I never
know I wake up each day just waking up
with no idea of what where to go or what
to do
I can't figure out where I'm going in
life all I know is I want to make my way
over to New York
or Minnesota more than likely Minnesota
because it was
the one state my grandfather lived in
and I used to go visit him and it's
where he's buried at and it was the
state my wife was born in and I want to
do everything I can to be close to my
wife
I'm making my way towards the the one
town that my grandfather lived in
Minnetonka to go start a life up there
and the freezing cold
because I believe
up there I'll probably be more sober
than I've ever been anywhere in my life
and that's all I want is to be up there
near my grandfather's spirit in the home
of my wife and just
it was so peaceful up there for me I
don't like it here I've never liked it I
I I hope one day my kids come looking
for me but right now I don't even know
where I am so
I need to find myself person
the only place I've ever felt at peace
was in the Summers I spent up in
Minnesota with my grandfather
counting all the Silver Leaf trees and
things like that my grandfather besides
my mother was the one person in my life
that never yell yell at me or lie to me
and never beat me
everyone in my family
guy's been an ass has lied manipulated
used mental health to get out of CPS
charges against abuse
and things like that and it's just been
one runny shitty stick after another
but that's the life I was meant to live
for some reason and that's the life I'll
live
all I know is that once I'm done with my
surgeries and I'm a girl
I'll be happier because all my life I've
been impressed up until the day I
started the hormones to begin everything
and Nevermore have I been more sure that
I'm on the right path in some way than I
was before I wouldn't even have been to
this point if it hadn't been for my wife
making me accept it and just get along
with it
I never accepted it until my wife
pointed it out and actually brought it
out at me
but that woman was the most important
thing in my life I went every day
thinking stupid profane
gory things that most we consider the
thoughts of an insane person and
honestly I'll say the day I met my wife
was the first day I can ever remember
having an actual sane thought in my head
and it's the first time I ever had a
will to do anything other than grow old
die on the streets being a drug addict
because that's what my goal of life was
before I met my wife just to stay high
until the day I die because I didn't
give a [ __ ] about anything
and then all of a sudden I had something
I cared about
back to your back to your childhood and
your family you
your relationship
with your parents was not so great
my dad was extremely abusive I had to
learn to hide bruises that would
Encompass everything from the bottom of
my jaw down to my shoulder blades with
makeup because if I got caught with the
bruises again the CPS got called again
I'd go back to the psychiatric ward for
a lying again as my grandma would
threaten me every time
so I got beat pretty aggressively pretty
badly
um I remember one time I he hit me for
sneezing while he was asleep
we're left to bruise half inch thick
spanning elbow to waist I was seven
years old and my stepmom and my
stepbrothers are soon to be stepmom and
all that uh saw what she did to me and
she broke off the engagement because she
wasn't gonna let somebody do that to one
of her two sons or daughter because that
was just unbelievable for what he did to
me it's a Bruce meter on the cop chart
because that woman called the cops for
me
they didn't have a Darkness to match the
bruise that had already formed in less
than two hours after being hit it was so
black and so so perfectly welted it
wasn't even funny they they did an
entire Statewide Manhunt for my dad
after that
um
he only did a year in prison for it and
still
continue to be an abusive [ __ ] and
still is one to this day I've been
picked up by him by by the neck
lifted over his head and he's six foot
five and slammed in the tile on ground
on the ground
just because I was wiggling a tooth I
had that was loose I mean this dude
isn't insane
uh and his mom will always try to you
know do everything she could to keep him
from going to jail for everything
including like letting him beat the [ __ ]
out of me and then I get to a
psychiatric report because he beat me
and I'm lying about it
the bruises and the way I react to
everyone doesn't see that I'm not
kidding how if it wasn't for my
grandmother and my wife he would be dead
right now I tried to kill him once
and I picked up a metal 50-pound piece
of metal and I swung it at his head my
grandma tackling me from the side my
wife tackling me in the chest at the
same time
I missed just enough to move every hair
on the back of that man's head and I was
going to kill him I still want to kill
him I hate him so much
um but I didn't because of my wife and
my grandmother I kind of cursed them for
it but at the same time I thank my wife
every day for it because I'm out here
still because I did
I just stay away from him because we
can't be in the same room more than 12
hours before we're trying to hurt each
other and I always have the intent to
kill him
after everything he's done to me I just
can't stand him my mother she was never
a bad mom but she was never a mom
even to this day she's struggling with
addiction she's currently a methadone
uh attic matte right now because she was
a heroin addict
and
if it wasn't for her though
I probably would have been one too like
I've tried heroin before but like I
never once liked it
and it was always be my reason for
always hating it was because my grand my
mom she freaked out on me one day
thinking I was on it and uh I was just
really stoned and she realized I get
that stoned and [ __ ]
she got on me she's like when we do
don't do heroin she was so so hateful
about heroin that I I love my mom so
much that I just no matter what I do I
just I've done it when I've had severe
jaw pains fractured bones and when I say
I've done it I've taken like five
dollars worth put it in a gallon of
water and drink that over like three
weeks time
so if you call that being actually doing
heroin then I've done heroin but if you
call it medicating then I've just used
it like Vicodin uh I've more or less
I did weed I didn't really care for any
other drug so I got with women who did
other drugs like speed and I started
associating with women like that more
and more
and um
yeah I started doing it not sure enough
I I've been a needle junkie for almost
10 years now
and I recently I can say that for the
last four months I have been free
needles I've never been happier in my
life but at the same time it it also
reminds me that
needles will always take you lower than
you've ever been in your life there's
not a person who can use needles that
does not eventually hit a bottom which
they could never have fathomed even if
they thought they hit rock bottom do
some needles and you'll know what real
Rock Bottom is
because you don't know where the Rock
Bottom is until you've lost every last
thing you have and you're nothing but
yourself
in a world where there's eight billion
people and it sucks when you're by
yourself and even when they're right
there next to you and you're talking to
them you'll be talking to the entire
civilization
and you're still alone
that's the worst that's when you're
really at rock bottom
you came out as transgender uh at what
age
uh approximately three years in the
relationship with my wife I finally
accepted it first time I was honest
myself about it I was 16 first time the
question was press to me by a therapist
I was 11 and I've always thought I was a
girl since before I was three that was
when my grandmother got me the address
was three years old and when I said can
I really be a girl I can really be a
girl she beat the [ __ ] on me because she
expected to be like any other kid boy
you get them a girl's gift they just cry
out why this is a girl's gift well I got
all excited and happy and she didn't
like that
my grandmother was a Baptist and really
against gay and trans type thing
and um
yeah so that was the beginning of my
medications did you tell me in the car
that there was a relative of yours that
is trans as well yeah that would be my
mom's dad 26 years now uh Jonathan has
no longer been Jonathan but now Lisa
Campbell
it's my mom's mom my grandmother and
she's a lesbian herself who only sticks
to women
um unlike me
I'm just homophobic beyond all belief
and more or less for social reasons I am
not gay
I like any one person because of a
personality now I'm just saying I'm not
gay that means that standpoint I
technically am straight but when I have
a sex change I will probably stay
straight unlike my grandmother and stay
lesbian then
I'm not too sure that's gonna be how it
is for me
I don't know why I'm like that but I
think it has something to do with the
fact that my grandmother who raised me
not to like gays and things like that
I always beat it in my head is how you
want the world to see you is that how
you want everyone to see you so as a
standpoint I think that's the only
reason why I don't associate I think yay
it's just because I can't stand the
thought of being looked at that way so
there's a good chance call you gay but
in the future I'll probably have a
husband
but for now I'm just straight guy a
straight girl in the guy's body
how do you support yourself
right now I support myself just by
food banks
kind donations every now and then
I I don't have a job I don't have
anything I I don't even know where I'm
going where do you stay at night up
until the 27th of this month I had an
apartment it was a
my wife and I got the apartment in
housing in her name just two weeks
before she died
and they didn't kick me out until after
the year was up
for some reason the housing paid paid
all the way further here
even though it should have been up right
there at the beginning right when we
moved in
so
I just sleep wherever and I mean
you and your cats yeah just me and my
two cats now
wherever we come across the place that's
you know the lights are turned on on the
street and I just feel like I'm gonna
pop a tent right there that's where I
pop a tank
my main goal is to to
you get through my surgeries and
everything out here and then when some
old girls start heading to Minnesota
and just go live in Minnesota and be
happy there from now on how will you pay
for your surgeries
luckily enough uh the state and I'm on
the right part of the state insurance
covers everything
so long as you just get the two
therapist signatures saying yeah it's
okay this is what he needs
the LA is one of the few places I know
of that is very very kind enough to
actually pay the entire surgery for you
they take care of everything all the way
through
from hormones to final surgery
so that's why I'll stay in the state
probably for another year and a half
that's how long I have left
in six months I can begin augmentations
which I first hope to do my voice and
then from there on out just whatever it
feels I need I'm not gonna get any chest
done
but I will get everything done in the
end
I'm just gonna be the girl I always
believed I was and always felt that I
was
what are you afraid of now
I'm really remembering this fear her
being 100 alone in the world
that's what I've always been afraid of
because we have no friends no family no
nothing
it's scary you just don't want to be
around anymore
uh I I'm afraid to each night each day
every second because I'm alone
I don't know where I'm headed where I'm
going or what I'm doing
because I don't have anyone to impress
so I don't want to do anything anymore
I just want to
I kind of just want to fade away into
into in the background
almost kind of like I lost my my spark
but I haven't
because I can't kill myself I promise my
wife and God I never would
even though I don't want to be here so
badly that's the one promise I made to
my wife I wouldn't kill myself you know
I almost did though I tried at one point
I didn't succeed as you can tell
but yeah I know my my biggest fear not
being hurt anything like that why is
it's just being alone
right now dying would be a blessing but
I'm not ready to accept it and God
doesn't say it'll say it hasn't so it's
time for me to do that either
if you had your life to live all over
again would you have done anything
differently
so much I would have done differently
there's so many key points in my life
that would have been so different
because I would still have my kids all
10 of them
I would still have my wife
you have 10 kids
yeah I have ten ate by my wife and two
by two other ladies my first one was
when I was 18.
um I think he would be with my wife my
third kid with my wife my fourth kid was
with uh you know my third kid was with
another girl my fourth kid was with my
wife I had an open relationship with my
wife
uh early on because
she felt it was something we should do
but
um a girl who had been dating on again
off again since I was 14. is the mother
of my third kid my second daughter
and then my wife had in three years
three sets of twins which were one boy
one girl one boy one boy one girl one
boy
every pregnancy was one form of a term
when premature when full-term one
premature one full-term one premature
because apparently my kids even though
they're all premature developed so
quickly that by the time they're uh
approximately six months along
they reached they read at 40 weeks
but they end up in IQ because their
lungs aren't developed and things like
that but they read they read full term
but because well I'm a junkie and a drug
addict I can't know the dates right they
induce labor each time and put my kids
in IQ and [ __ ] I have to yell at them
and
yeah
where are you kids now CPS
me nor my wife
we're we're hella parents like when I
say it comes to the aspect of being a
mother and father yeah we're damn sure I
could follow him like no other she can
mother them like no other but actually
being a parent that raises the kid
that's not me
I'm too immature and too too responsible
pay attention how can I afford to pay
for a kid let alone give it the
attention it needs
unfortunately neglectable because I was
raised I had to raise myself and I
really don't know what the meaning of
being a real parent is neither did my
wife my wife got too jealous of her own
kids attention from the dad
to where it was unhealthy by the time
our kid was four he could barely speak
so
we're not parents but we are mothers and
fathers yes
now
I wish I could have been a better parent
I wish I would have been the parent I
could have
but there are those who can't even be a
mother or father that can be a parent
and they should have the chance to be in
because they might be able to get my kid
10 times more better than I can ever do
for my kid just because they want to and
they can't
and I don't want to even though I can
so I leave my kids to whoever and
wherever they are just knowing that they
are doing better than I could have ever
done for them
hopefully I can't promise that because
they never know who gets your kids in
the end
but
I just hope they do better
than I did and I hope they have the best
life they can
in turn what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
I've learned so many lessons but right
now
the greatest lesson I need to learn is
what exactly
Islam because I thought I knew how to
show love
and I guess the greatest lesson right
now I've learned is I don't know how to
show love properly
or love myself properly
and I need to learn how to show love be
loved and love myself before I could do
that for anyone
because all I know how to do is show
hate
that's all I ever so my wife was hate
and I hate myself so much for it
she let me unconditionally for all the
pieces of [ __ ] I was and all the wrongs
I ever did she let me unconditionally
and I just showed her nothing but hey
I thought I was showing her love
I swear she deserves so much better than
I ever did for her
all right Taryn thank you so much for
sharing your story
thank you I wish you and your cats
a lot of luck thank you thank you
hopefully it helps someone